and now this more Democrats are talking
about impeaching President Trump but the
party's leaders say they're not ready to
do it
Speaker of the House Nancy Pelosi urged
caution during a conference call with
House Democrats last night
she says they should focus on
investigations to uncover the truth
about the president other Democrats
including some running for presidents
say Congress has enough information to
begin impeachment proceedings right now
Nancy cortices on Capitol Hill with all
this Nancy good morning good morning
impeachment has become a key focus of
debate among Democrats both in Congress
and on the presidential campaign trail
after the Muller report outlined ten
different incidents that could be viewed
as evidence of obstruction of justice I
believe Congress should take the steps
towards the Pietschmann after simmering
for two years impeachment talk is
suddenly at full boil if any other human
being in this country had done what's
documented in the Mahler report they
would be arrested and put in jail but
not all Democrats are there yet if for
the next year year and a half going
right into the heart of the election all
that the Congress is talking about is
impeaching Trump and Trump Trump Trump
and Mulla Mulla Mulla and we're not
talking about health care we're not
talking about raising the minimum wage
to a living wage what I worry about is
that works the Trump's advantage if
we're only talking about him then folks
at home feel like nobody's talking about
them House Speaker Nancy Pelosi tried to
quell impeachment talk on a conference
call with party members last night
telling colleagues we don't have to go
to articles of impeachment to obtain the
facts but some of her members disagreed
Florida's Val Demings telling Pelosi I
think we have great evidence that the
president has blatantly violated so many
laws it's just ridiculous
I think we have enough
[Music]
but even as president Trump shrugged off
the notion at the White House Easter Egg
Roll the chair of the House Judiciary
Committee Jerry Nadler was issuing yet
another subpoena this time for testimony
and documents from former White House
Counsel Don McGann who Nadler described
as a critical witness to many of the
alleged instances of obstruction of
justice
Republicans say Democrats are grasping
at straws
noting McGann sat for more than 30 hours
of interviews with the special counsels
investigation while Pelosi is rejecting
immediate impeachment hearings she isn't
taking it off the table altogether she
said last night quote if that's the
place that the facts take us then that's
the place we have to go Norah
Moran it'll continue Thank You Nancy